Excuse me,
ladies and gentlemen.
My name is Samaria Johnson.
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Well, I didn't really come out.
Like, when I hear young people
talking about,
"I gathered everybody
in the living room..."
(LAUGHTER)
"Excuse me,
I have something to say."
(TAPE REWINDS)
♪ ("CRAZY" BY DOECHII PLAYS) ♪
-Oh!
-(LAUGHTER)
I ask the hard questions.
-Do you think I'm an alcoholic?
-Um...
If I only freeze my head,
is it, like, cheaper?
It is cheaper.
It's a broke people thing
to only freeze your head.
-That's right.
-(TAPE REWINDS)
We are a hot wife
slash cuckold couple.
Y'all want some
Eyes Wide Shut shit.
(LAUGHTER)
I'm a lesbian, obviously.
We don't wanna have no kids,
but I got a cat.
Could I, like, leave my car
to my cat?
-You can.
-That's cool.
(TAPE REWINDS)
My brother, he got locked up
when he was 18.
He came out of jail a dude
that loves pepperoni sticks now
and wearing his phone
on his belt.
He could feel just as
uncomfortable around you
as you do around him.
As a gay person,
I do check if a place
is gay-friendly.
I don't want to be overseas
breaking all the rules.
If I'm holding my bitch hand,
and I'm like,
"Whoa, whoa, whoa!"
If we present what we are,
which is messy...
Because people are messy.
-All bets are off.
-Dope.
And if you show all of it,
you leave room for everybody.
But I just like bitches
and hanging out with my homies.
That's a whole 'nother episode.
-FRIEND: Oh!
-(SAM JAY LAUGHS)
(TAPE REWINDS)
I'm from Boston, bro.
I've been around
the whitest of whites.
What's a wine expert called?
-SPEAKER: Sommelier.
-Sommelier.
-Like, I'm that of crackers.
-(LAUGHTER)